[Music]
Royall
a skirt day one laughs Annie wouldn't be
this extraordinarily prestigious fixture
without his opening with the traditional
royal procession Meghan Markel and
Prince Harry joined Queen Elizabeth for
the first day of Royal Ascot exactly one
month after their fairytale wedding at
Windsor Castle the two had lunch with a
92 year old royal before joining Prince
Edward and Sophie the Countess of Wessex
at the horse racing event for a carriage
ride the newly minted Duchess of Sussex
looked chic in a white G von Chi
ensemble with a matching hat by Philip
Treacy while Harry looked dapper in a
tail coat and top hat the lovebirds
appeared happier than ever walking
arm-in-arm and chatting with Prince
Charles and Camilla before joining the
Queen in the Royal Box just in time to
watch the first race they received that
trophy from Prince Harry and his new
bride now the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
who were in the royal procession in the
third carriage today it's believed to be
the first time that megan has been to
the famous races the outing comes just
one day after her father appeared on
British TV to talk about his famous
daughter and his staged paparazzi pics I
spoke to them both and I apologized I
realized it was a serious mistake but
hard to take it back now a royal source
tells ET that the newlyweds weren't too
pleased about his sit-down interview
quote they were not given advanced
warning they understand he has been
harassed by the paparazzi 24/7 but it's
hard for them to accept his apology when
he's again taking cash adding Megan
loves her father deeply and Harry and
Megan have tried to offer him support
and guidance adjusting to the media
attention but the relationship is
fractured